[MUSIC PLAYING]
KYLE MOSCHETTO: Let's start
with the Google Cloud migration
journey.
We have been showing this to
customers for a very long time.
And as more and more customers
migrate their workloads
to Google Cloud, we've
been able to validate this
over, and over, and over again.
And the key thing
to this, the reason
we keep talking about
that is because it works.
It takes an inherently
complex and monstrous process
of a cloud migration
and puts it down
into very manageable and
executable chunks of work.
Now, we know that this has
to happen in specific order.
We discover and assess
our application landscape.
We build the foundation
of GCP services
from IAM, and networking,
and basic architecture.
Then we actually perform
the migration itself.
And once that migration is done,
you assess all of the things
that you assumed in the process.
And you go ahead
and start optimizing
for cost, or performance,
or capability,
or whatever your
application needs.
And then it's also
important to remember
that there are multiple
ways that we can get there.
You can do traditional
Lift and Shift,
where you just want to
lower the overall complexity
and increase the speed of
moving services to the cloud.
You can do the Improve
and Move, where
you want to refactor
some local code in order
to take advantage of
cloud native tools
before you actually
migrate the services up.
Or you can do Rip and
Replace, where you just
want to start over with
the full toolkit of cloud
at your fingertips.
But the key thing to this--
and as anyone in the room who's
ever done a cloud migration
can tell you--
is we all hear that story
of no two cloud migrations
are ever the same.
And I'm going to clarify
that statement for the room.
There's a personal stand
I want to take here,
which is that all successful
cloud migrations are
unique in their own
way because you all
have different technologies,
and industry verticals,
and data centers, and
all of these things.
But all failed
cloud migrations all
fail for the exact same reason.
They either didn't have
a plan to begin with,
or they didn't stick to the
plan that they built on.
And we know that
these things are
incredibly easy to talk
about and incredibly
hard to actually execute.
And when we see a customer
that comes through, follows
this journey, makes
a plan, and has
a passion for learning,
exploring, and testing,
we see success.
And today is the story
of one such customer
in Kroger Digital.
I'd like to introduce Joe
Timmons, a technical account
manager here at Google, to
begin the rest of the story.
JOE TIMMONS: Awesome.
Thank you, Kyle.
So, I am in the Google
Cloud Professional Services
Organization.
And for the last
year and a half,
I've had the
privilege of working
with Kroger in Cincinnati
on their migration journey.
And I just want to talk a
little bit about that today.
But before I dive
into that, I want
to talk more broadly about why
retailers love Google Cloud.
So in order to think about
where we're going in retail,
let's first take a minute
and look backwards.
I'm kind of bitter
because I missed
the cool attribute of being
a millennial by two years.
So I was born two
years too early
to be called a millennial.
But growing up in the 80s
and 90s, in terms of retail,
all you had was a retail brick
and mortar store or a catalog.
That was pretty much it.
And malls were the thing.
Everybody went to the mall,
and everybody loved the mall.
And my priority at that
time was buying apparel.
So when I went to
the mall, I would
go in and buy the latest and
greatest in the coolest shirts.
And let's think about
that experience.
And has that experience
changed that much
from 25 years ago
to today, if we
were to walk in to
those same brands
that I bought from before?
Not that much.
However, the next
25 years are going
to be incredible for the
brick and mortar store.
I believe it will be
a renaissance because
of a confluence of
incredible technologies
that are all coming together
at the right time to do that.
Technologies like computer
vision, IoT, Edge Compute,
Machine Learning, and
obviously, the public cloud--
using all of these
technologies together,
the customer experience
will be totally
transformed, not only digitally,
but also in the store.
And that's what we hear
from a lot of our retailers
that I talk to is that
that omnichannel seamless
experience is their priority.
Warren Buffett has
a famous quote.
He says the most
important decision
that you'll make in your
life is who you marry.
And we believe at Google Cloud,
the most important decision
that you will make,
or your CIO will make,
is which cloud they
choose to innovate with.
So let's talk about Kroger--
136-year-old company,
started in Cincinnati.
And they have over 2,800
retail stores, multiple brands.
They do have a $5
billion digital run rate,
and they're growing
like gangbusters online
at a 58% growth last quarter.
60 million families
rely on Kroger
annually to serve them for
their groceries, as well
as 14 million shoppers pass
through their doors every day.
And Kroger has this
amazing purpose
that they have stated that they
want to feed the human spirit.
And they're also going through
a huge digital transformation.
And they call that digital
transformation Restock Kroger.
And we've been proud to be
a big part of that strategy
over the last year and a half.
So what were Google
Cloud's goals?
What was the whole point?
What was their stated mission
in adopting the Google Cloud?
So, they have these pillars
that they talk about
in Kroger Digital, where they
want their digital entities
to be available, accessible,
and relevant to their customers.
And that equals a better
customer experience.
And they also wanted an
accelerated transformation.
So that's where the Google
Cloud Professional Services
team and our partner
network came into play,
where we could send
teams of people side
by side with Kroger
engineers and help them
not only through their
migration itself, but to plan
out all of those
technical attributes that
need to be decided to do any
large scale cloud migration.
And then finally, the
key thing that Kroger
wanted to do with
Google Cloud was
to be their innovation partner.
So the buzzword
obviously AI, ML.
And what that
really boils down to
is to better understanding
their customers.
And the interesting
thing that Kroger found
is that the more relevant they
made their digital experience
for their customers,
counter-intuitive thing
happened.
Actually, more customers
visited their stores.
And they spent more
time in the stores,
which is an incredible
outcome for all of you
who also have this omnichannel
experience that you're
trying to improve, and
motivate, and build.
So the key thing, before
I pass it over to Jeff,
is that if you leave this
conference thinking that cloud
is just VMs in somebody
else's data center,
you've missed the point.
The real opportunity to
partner with Google Cloud
is the opportunity to transform
your business for the next 25
years in retail.
And with that, I'll
pass it over to Jeff.
JEFFREY HECHT: Thanks, Joe.
So, I'm Jeff Hecht.
I'm the engineering manager
for the Digital Search team
specifically within Kroger.
This is the search
engine that's used
for the website, and the mobile
app, and things like that.
So, kind of, where
do you start, right?
And so where we
chose to start was,
what are we currently using
that supports our business?
What got us to where
we are today, but isn't
going to take us to the next
level that Joe is referring to?
So I think this diagram that
we have here really describes
things well, right?
We've got a mix of a lot
of different technologies.
You guys are
probably-- a lot of you
guys are probably using a lot
of this technology yourselves,
right?
But we're doing it
all on-prem, right?
And it's time to sort
of kick it into gear
and take it to the
next level, right?
And so the big
question we had was,
do we do a Lift and
Shift type thing?
Do we take our existing search
strategy that we're doing?
Do we move that out there and
realize the benefits of GCP
in that way?
Or is this something that we
can do to completely re-platform
the search solution
that we have,
which is ultimately
what we chose to do.
So as we got into this, we--
it's kind of
overwhelming, right?
It's like, OK, cool, we're
going to go to the cloud.
All right, cool.
How do we get there?
What do we do?
So, we had three
different options, right?
The first option is, do we
do it all ourselves, right?
That's a tall task, especially
when we have limited experience
in GCP on our staff, right?
And we still have to keep
the old thing running.
So these are all real business
problems that we have, right?
So the next thing,
right, is to--
OK, so should we just basically
partner with Google, right?
And utilize their
professional services teams,
the technical account
managers, and the consultants
to make this happen.
Now they've got
loads of experience,
and we can probably
get there quickly.
But ultimately
what we want is we
want to have that center of
excellence in our teams, right?
And so that's where we chose
ultimately kind of option three
that you see up on the screen
there, which is we kind of
did a hybrid, right?
So we have our team
working with Google
and one of the Google
Partners, preferred partners.
We used Spring ML in this case.
And basically, we had Spring ML
and Google resources literally
shoulder to shoulder,
pairing at workstations,
building the software defined
architecture and things
that we built here to
make all this happen.
And in the end, we
ended up not only
producing a really
awesome solution for this,
but we also have people
who are vested in it
and understand how
it works, right?
So the way we kind
of arrived at this
is we got everybody in a room,
a big room, three days, I think.
And we had several Kroger
engineers, several Google
folks, several Spring ML folks.
And we started with, OK, what
is the thing that we have today?
And where do we want
to take this, right?
And so we got all of our tribal
knowledge, all this stuff
that's the intangibles, right?
We drug all that out, and
everything we wanted it to be.
And essentially,
coming out of that,
we ended up with this, what I
called a reference architecture
of not only for search, but for
a lot of the other applications
that we're moving out
to the cloud as well.
And one of the big
founding tenets that we had
is everything
infrastructure as code.
Everything
Nothing-- no console
stuff, right?
We want to be able to be able
to spin these things up, tear it
down, iterate, iterate, iterate.
So that was huge for us.
So there again, the other
point that you see there
with the building
and adapt and move on
is the infrastructure as code
pieces were really valuable
for us to be able
to do this right.
And we're never
building something
that we can't build again,
and again, and again, right?
So we failed a lot, right?
So don't be afraid to fail.
I'll raise my hand and say
the biggest lessons I've ever
had in life are the ones
where I did something
wrong and fixing it by doing
it over, and over, and over.
And then you guys
have all seen the pets
versus livestock thing.
This is truly a huge, huge tenet
in moving your applications
out there.
You've got to get away from
having these special purpose
things.
This host-- it does
this thing, right?
You've got to get
away from that.
And so when the guys would
come up to me, they would say,
hey, this is really great.
We got the new thing
working, right?
And I'd say, that's
really awesome, guys.
I'm really glad for you.
Tear it down and do it again.
And do it again,
and do it again.
And the team was fantastic.
They did a great job with that.
So as we did this, we started
to see our mindset change.
We went from this on-prem
pets sort of mentality,
right, to one where we were
expecting transient resources,
and things like that, and being
able to move workloads around
very easily.
Some of the other things that
we kind of struggled with,
more of as a global
Kroger we, is things
like data classification.
What's safe?
What are things we feel
comfortable moving out
to the cloud?
This is our first thing, right?
What are things that we
feel comfortable moving
to the cloud?
Search was obviously
a pretty easy decision
to make because all that stuff's
available on the internet
today, right?
So there's not a whole lot we're
going to be throwing out there
that everybody who's crawling
us doesn't already have, right?
And then also being able to
trust and empower our engineers
to do things that maybe they
haven't done before, right?
If you think about
on-prem, right, you've
got a team of guys that
are standing up VMs.
You have people
installing the OS
and doing that kind
of thing, right?
Where this is different, right?
We've got Kubernetes, and
we've got these [INAUDIBLE]
containers of things.
And we are really embracing the
DevOps on both sides of that,
right?
I mean, development
and operations--
our team has really done a great
job supporting both of those.
So it's not all unicorns
and rainbows, though.
We had quite a few speed bumps.
Networking-- getting networks
installed into our on-prem data
centers and things like that was
sometimes a bit of a challenge.
And in fact, I think
one of our data centers,
we didn't even have the
right kind of fiber line.
And so we had to run a fiber
line or something out there.
It's all these things that
you don't think about, right,
when you're building--
when you go,
oh, yeah, we're going to move
an application out there.
And then you've got to think,
what does this actually mean?
We're going to put
customers on this stuff.
What do we have to have, right?
And these are all
these intangibles
that you've got to
think about as you
start moving your
applications out there, right?
It's kind of a big deal.
Some simple things, like even
our CI/CD pipelines, right?
On our on-prem solution,
we're deploying our containers
in a blue green fashion.
And it's something we
don't even think about.
It's in-house tooling.
OK, we go to GCP, and we're
deploying our applications
to our Kubernetes clusters.
And OK, wow, how are we going
to do blue green deployment?
Because this is expected
for what we have.
So this is also kind of
things that sort of snuck up
on us as we moved along.
And I could just kind of
keep going, and going,
and going on that thing.
The important thing
here is when you're
doing your discovery phase,
think about the stuff
that you take for
granted when you're
trying to plan this
stuff out and put
your timelines together, right?
So given that, I'm going
to pass the mic over here
to Tony DiLoreto.
He is a cloud
consultant from Google.
And we worked very closely
with Tony and his team
to make all this stuff happen.
TONY DILORETO: Thanks, Jeff.
So yes, as Jeff said, my
name is Tony DiLoreto.
I was the cloud
consultant working
with Jeff's team to help
the migration and all
the architecture.
I want to walk you
through now just how we
thought about building out
this new system on GCP, right?
But before we could even
move the first byte,
we had to have a plan in
place, like we talked about.
And we wanted to make sure that
we would cover all the bases,
and we had everything in
the cloud ready to go.
So to do so, I wanted to
focus on five key points.
And they all begin with an
S. I call them the five S's.
Simplification, right?
You'll see in a
second what we went
from to what we ended up with.
Security-- making sure it
was secure in the cloud.
Stability-- being
able to grow and scale
with our customer base.
Kroger, being a
national company,
has customers all
over the United States
and in the world
coming to the website,
so we wanted to make sure
we could grow with that.
Data science, the
science bit, and finally,
microservices, right?
All of these different pieces--
what we had to incorporate into
the architecture to make sure
that this application could
grow with Kroger and its
customers' needs.
So as we already saw, this
is what I walked into.
And again, probably
not dissimilar to what
many other people here
are using today, right?
We have sort of this
search Frankenstack,
if you will, with a lot
of different platforms,
where the teams had to manage
all the different releases
and patches in
security and platforms,
and making sure that all
of the infrastructure
was set up for it, and ports.
The list goes on and on.
This is obviously one
of the true benefits
of migrating to the
cloud, is not having
to deal with all of that.
But this is where
we started with.
This was our beginning
point of the roadmap.
And there were a lot
of different areas
of which we had to ensure
that we incorporated
into this architecture not only
just the platforms themselves
and the technology, but testing
and validation, rolling out,
being able to make
sure there were
no single points of failure.
And all the while, ensuring
that the data was at the right
place at the right time.
So like I said, the
first thing we focused on
was the simplification
of this architecture.
We wanted to go from this
multi-tenant multi-platform
stack into something
straightforward.
And as you know, probably
with any application,
there are a few key elements or
key phases to the architecture
that it needs to include.
So, this is the
initial sort of look
at what we had to
migrate to, incorporating
those key tenets, the ingestion
of data coming in from Kroger.
The transformation of the data--
how are we going to
prepare it for being used?
Storage in some vehicle
within Google Cloud,
and then like Jeff
mentioned, running
on Kubernetes, or
the application
layer of which all the customers
could then interact with.
Again, this is a very
solid baseline template
for almost any
application running
in the cloud because it
does incorporate many
of those key tenets
of a pipeline
or of an application
running in the cloud.
One of the best things that
Google has the advantage
is to come in and just
drop in and replace some
of the existing infrastructure.
We are able to identify in that
previous architecture which
of these elements lined up
to the different hexagons
and the different
verticals you see in here.
Doing so allowed us to
iterate fast, sometimes
fail fast, but iterate rapidly
and to continue to move on.
The next thing we
focused on was stability.
Again, I wanted to make
sure that we had the ability
to grow and handle
traffic as Kroger grew.
As you saw at the very
beginning, Kroger has been.
And we wanted to be able
to capture all of that
and to deliver those low latency
and high durability stability
requirements.
So we could have
easily have just taken
a visual architecture and
just copied into three zones
and been done with it.
But anybody who's been using
any sort of cloud service
or managed service
in the past knows
that this isn't the
optimal way of doing so.
Where Google really
shines, again,
is having those managed services
that scale with the customers,
where you don't have to
worry about bringing up
your own instances
of them for things
such as Pub/Sub at the very
beginning, or a data flow.
So what we were able to
do is we iterated on this,
but having it in multiple
regions allowed that layer
to be able to grow, and
scale, and handle customers
wherever they were.
The next thing we wanted to do
was focus on scaling this out.
So we took that architecture
that we just looked at,
and we sort of condensed
it down to what we really
wanted to focus on--
really, what is
Kroger's IP and what
they should be bringing in.
And that's really in that
application layer, right?
All of the other hexagons
to the left, that's Google
managed services that we've
built, and tried and true
and tested.
So let's really focus on
what makes the Kroger search
application unique.
So what we were
able to do is focus
on deploying applications
in a rolling manner
into each of the different
regions within Google
Kubernetes Engine.
Once we're able to do that
initially through a test,
we wanted to focus
more on the service
aspect, that
service-oriented architecture
that you always hear about.
So we're able to break
it up into multiple apps.
And every app could then
do what it was made for.
Imagine moving a giant monolith
to a more nimble and service
focused application itself.
This pattern is very simple
to then grow within scale.
And as you could see, once
you have one app down,
you can easily replicate
it to many others.
This architecture
that you end up seeing
is not dissimilar from what
we ended up pushing forward.
And again, it is a
tried and true pattern
that you can then use for
any of your applications.
Kubernetes allowed
us to scale, and it
allowed us to be
able to really focus
on what Kroger needed to do.
The next thing we had to
focus on was security.
Obviously, security is
very important to everybody
that's using Google Cloud.
So some of the
key considerations
that we thought about
when building out
this first initial
architecture of using Google
managed services are number
one, if you can use Google
managed services, it takes
that responsibility away
from having a single
point or single person
worrying about managing
different instances.
The next thing were
service accounts as well.
Service accounts were
deployed throughout.
And again, it's one
of our best practices.
By enabling extensive
logging and monitoring,
we're able to get at
any issues immediately
to be able to detect and to
be able to optimize around.
Finally, key
management, making sure
that all the data
that was going through
was secure at rest
and in transit.
And finally, we also
use managed node pools
to be able to ensure that
we had enough architecture
or enough infrastructure
when we needed it.
And finally, the last
thing we focused on
was the science aspect, right?
Everybody, again, wants
to get to the AI, the ML.
But after we were able to
build out this architecture,
then we could really
dive into that.
So some of the
different areas that
are opportunities for doing data
science with an architecture,
one was real time ingestion
or streaming analytics.
So when the data was coming in,
do we see any issues with that?
Second was data
quality analytics
once we're doing our
transformation on the data.
Did we notice that any of our
providers or upstream sources
had issues or was
delivering at the wrong time
that we needed to correct?
Third was any sorts of
prescriptive or predictive
analytics on top of the
data once it was in storage.
Being able to do modeling
and be able to get at really
what are customers' data is key.
And then finally, the usage of
customer analytics on the app
itself--
where are they
interacting with the app?
What are their points
of confusion or areas
that we can then improve
for the next iteration?
And what that, I'm
going to turn it back
over to Jeff to talk a little
about the lessons learned
and the next steps.
JEFFREY HECHT: Yeah,
so lessons learned--
I don't think I have enough
time to go through all
the lessons learned, right?
But some of the important
takeaways, right?
It's important to understand
that my focus and my team's
focus is primarily on search,
and relevance, and things
like that.
And one of the important
things that we're doing
is we're doing actual
data science now
to let our customers'
actions on our site talk
to us about what
types of products
we should be returning based
on those types of search terms.
And that's that AI,
ML thing that Tony
was talking about there.
And that's real big
for us with what
we're doing in
some Dataproc stuff
that we have set up internally.
We have a system called Agatha.
And so we're actually doing
real data science on this
to be able to do
this type of stuff.
The other thing
that's great is we're
able to launch
completely new stacks,
fully populate them with
content and everything,
literally with the
click of a button.
One of the guys on my team,
Jim, literally, on Saturday,
spun up a new environment that
we needed for some testing.
And the whole thing took an
hour to build the entire search
stack.
So that goes back to that whole
infrastructure as code piece.
It's huge, right?
The other nice
thing that you can
probably saw on those diagrams
that Tony had up there,
but is the scaling
factor of this.
We literally can scale
this thing out to infinity.
It's really easy for
us to do that now.
And then the new search
platform-- and a lot of this
is based on some of the
GCP tools that we're using.
A lot of this is also based
on the re-architecture
that we did of
the search engine.
But we can handle
orders of magnitude
more volume than we
did before with just
an amazing improvement in
response time and stuff.
So it's the whole
re-architecture.
And then dropping it on GCP was
just of absolute benefit to us.
So, right.
What does this mean,
then, for the future
of Kroger on the cloud?
There's a ton of work
to do here, right?
Lots of workloads to go,
more than I can talk about.
Here are some of
those potentially
Lift and Shift, some of those
re-architecture type things.
But the important thing
to take away from this
is that our application really
broke down a lot of barriers
for the teams that are sort
of riding on our coattails
and following along.
So that helps to accelerate
the rest of those applications
and those teams, which is
super important for Kroger
and ultimately our customers
to be able to take that
to the next level.
And then the other
nice thing that's
about it, working with
the Google guys, is--
if I could put this in one
sentence, I think it was,
how can I help you
help Kroger, right?
I can't tell you how many
times Tony would give me a call
and say, hey, I've got these
guys from BQ, from BigQuery.
And they want to
understand what's
important to you for how
you're doing your Machine
Learning, and your AI,
and things like that.
And we'd hop on a phone call
and have these discussions.
And that's the first
time that I've ever
had a partner get
with me and say,
I want to make your job easier.
What can I do to do this?
It's usually me
saying, hey, this thing
that we're trying
to use doesn't work.
Or I need to pound this square
peg through this round hole.
And so that's been fantastic.
I've really enjoyed that, too.
And it's kind of
cool to also think
that things that are
important to us as Kroger
might actually be influencing
products and things that Google
is going to develop someday that
might be beneficial to you guys
as well.
So that's pretty great.
That's pretty cool.
[MUSIC PLAYING]